welcome to this video playing step by
step yeah yeah frequent opponent and we
practice this year all day long going to
do it again I'm just to be be principled
about it but may I should try something
else series playing that well III emits
I'll probably you go to transpose
because at some point hmm interesting if
I go if I've now is there some 95
business hmm 'if I've 95 mb should be
292 hmm but unsure don't think it should
be that great firm but let's try yeah
it's not really doing any of that okay
so let's quickly check it i go 94 years
this this is something worth considering
no it's just blunder stuff so I'm going
back to be eight spend a bit too much of
time for that okay so night bd7 probably
all start with a five
oh that's interesting this position it's
a bit uncommon a five i wonder if i
should flick in a five or not probably i
should do that he's going 92 now I guess
a five and he will go be three sa4 is a
bit awkward no this one that's
interesting check and it's interesting
so this might be a position where I can
play b5 TX not be six but it's got Eve
form so probably not that great hmm i
also see five i can just stay somewhat
passive with b6 which is not the
greatest way ever to play okay come on
it's a sim is a deadly simple to play
with the bishop being on a 1 this is not
not that terrible a fall I don't want to
stay on be 70 in the long run but it's
it's it's possible to play like that for
the moment yeah not be five yeah this is
I thought you should have played a form
i was I'm a bit surprised that you
didn't do that ok so I ok he wants if i
take he wants to play night c 4 285 i am
ok that's definitely an IDM and came
anyway so Bishop a six maybe he's got p5
oh this is an okay he can take them he
can take an IP 60 contain hmm but
awkward it looks really bad for me but
I'm not sure how bad it really is b5
I've got night c5 maybe he can take on a
six but now i can take b3 and c5 this
pawn will probably drop okay it's rook
da to move next probably not I have
light a four-night a for Queen most
nights III can take a six which is kind
of awkward but here wait um I think I'll
just go here efore is hanging after all
let's still have night a four in the mix
night a for Queen moves
maybe justice should be said met maybe
just Bishop d7 combining those ideas
night a 400 be aid i'm pat down on the
clock where did I spent that time I
really sometimes ask ourselves where did
I spent the time
over to be six with the Queen so he
wants to go Queen Queen 86 after to
trade okay just a many to make sure that
my night is doing something that idea of
him playing a v6 is very annoying at at
some stage so I have to make sure that
my night is actually some more activated
try to activate it on f6 interesting
time warning yeah this is the biggest
problem actually I'm not sure about the
position at all a point is dangerous but
I get a counter-attack okay I've got one
minute that's not that bad
so if I check check and take a seven I
don't believe this at all where are you
actually going I can also check on a one
now King see too well this hasn't
screamed you for some the best you can
do is just some kind of Perpetual you
can take f7 maybe and hope that I'm not
meeting him probably check was just a
with justification check
check-check
check all rights difficult check check
check check yeah the time the time is
the problem check check I've got six
seconds check check jam it's useless I
heard some kind of Perpetual check rah
yeah not I doubt he doesn't take the
draw that's clear I just wanted to make
a check of there some kind of repetition
it's a dead draw of course yeah i just i
spent far too much time here at some
point i don't know where exactly every
move just cost some time position was
kind of okay i mean here black is worse
a little bit and due to the space but
yeah and here's start to be start to be
okay he didn't really think about 95 i
guess yeah yeah I'm totally totally fine
yeah not sure if this was great getting
into this position that's actually
really questionable maybe I should
really go here here first and and to
take take this kind of position of sizes
and no 97 and 95 this is strong I am
because given the choice I don't want to
take on c6 yeah this disposition
this position I gets gets its tricky for
me it's definitely tricky for me yeah
after that it's a draw but here you can
play Queen d2 and win now I don't really
get I don't get them here I don't get
enough here because the pawn is quicker
Here I am actually winning but well yeah
okay I took the porn at the compounds to
do this thing is if I take jack we
promote so which is what what did the
end you'll just say okay engine just
stated that this is a draw as you can't
it's kind of funny my king is safe he
and I have enough public power to 2-2
draw yeah that's funny with them with
with the perpetual it's funny already
okay but this is of course okay check
it's just a draw right okay 20 seconds
you can change and run around with the
king at some point I can also win here
it is really matter because with the
time we can play any any kind of stuff
and we know time which is the problem
here because I spent the spent here
where would it has spent that much time
I really want to know yeah it's still
kind of okay okay
and here I'm kind of okay of 30 seconds
here yeah it's some seconds per move
this is sometimes they're really the
problem if you're doing the commentary
you'd see something and it costs a
couple of seconds and it piles up
sometimes especially if the opponent is
playing relatively quickly I mean it's
not like dashing out moves all the time
but he's playing relatively quickly and
then you you get into this this time
issues okay well thanks for watching